oh wow yeah yeah listen we're just going
to ask a couple of questions I'm sorry
I'm just
you're like an honest to God Detective
yeah the Yellow Jacket season two is
over and I find myself in the same place
I was after season one I've got a lot of
questions some are pressing some are
lingering some will probably never get
answered some are curious and some are
crucial but they're all burning in their
own way at least just as the yellow
jackets cabin was the last time we saw
it before we get to that when I did my
season one recap I did that based on the
questions we had going into season two
so I went back to see how many of those
were answered it turns out most of them
were Beyond a couple of key points and I
think the focus now has changed to how
we think about these things after season
two is over the pick girl is the perfect
example it's clear that by the time we
get to the next winner when that happens
we'll already have seen them do just as
bad or worse so the question about that
now is whether there is anything of
interest there or if it was just a
device to hint how bad things were going
to get at the beginning of the series
the answer of who dies in that scene
will likely be answered through the
process of elimination by that point so
will there be something else of note
going on there or will it just be their
last hurray before they get rescued the
other question is the presence of a
supernatural force that guides things
and I think since we know that the
possibility of that is enough to
influence the choices they make in the
wilderness the question becomes will
this ever be confirmed one way or the
other I always like the idea of keeping
it open-ended and Beyond The Strange
shot that appears to be from the point
of view of the gust of wind that dropped
the snow on Jackie's funeral pyre and
the drop of blood spilling on the symbol
before the birds fell from the sky the
show didn't really make a clear move to
confirm or deny it this is an idea we'll
come back around to in relation to
several of these questions so let's get
into them the biggest burning question I
have after the season 2 finale is
whether or not but there will be a bonus
episode that might sound like a weird
question if you haven't been following
discussion around the show that closely
but if you have you know exactly what
I'm talking about most of us had been
expecting to see at least something
about the cabin guy if not a whole
episode but here we are at the end of
season two and it never came up some of
the reasons behind that were co-show
Runner Jonathan Lithgow mentioning in
interviews that they had thought up a
whole shining us backstory about this
character and they were hoping to
include it in the second season there
was a casting announcement for Melanie
lynskey's husband Jason Ritter and when
she was asked about that she mentioned
that he did work on the show this season
but they hadn't shared any scenes
together this made it seem like his
story would probably be tied to the
Wilderness but to this point we haven't
seen the girls run into anyone out there
then there were the behind the scenes
photos where you see him wearing the
winter coat they found in the the cabin
that almost everyone wears at one time
or another which of course screams that
this must be a flashback finally co-show
Runner Ashley Lau responded in a tweet
about the season only having Nine
episodes hinting that there could be a
bonus episode so this isn't coming from
nowhere and it might eventually come out
so I'll just leave this one there and
just say that I hope we learn more about
this character before everything's said
and done because now who knows the cabin
is burnt down but there are still a few
questions about that on top of the list
is whether or not Ben is responsible as
far as we saw in the finale this seems
to be the case he's lurking around the
cabin after dark he finds the box of
matches and then probably most
importantly he sees Nat look excited to
be named the leader and that looks like
the last connection to any sort of
Sanity for the group from his point of
view if he didn't do it are there even
any other options the only one that I
can think of that sort of makes sense
would be that he returned to the cave
with the matches and then someone else
took them went and blocked the exits and
then set the cabin on fire this person
then would almost have to be the same
person or from the same group of people
who hobby referred to as his friend and
part of the reason I wanted to see this
episode about the hunter or the cabin
guy or cabin daddy if you prefer as the
internet likes to refer to him part of
the reason I wanted to see that was
because he had his daughter with him in
those behind the scenes photos if he
were to go crazy and he tried to
annihilate his family any survivors that
were left would be the top candidate for
who Hobby's friend was I know that there
is the popular theory that his friend
was actually the other tie but that's a
pretty boring explanation that goes
nowhere story wise it went nowhere
before he died if you think it out but
the only possible evidence besides the
fact that she walks in her sleep being
that the missing Lantern was in the cave
and now that he's gone it doesn't add
anything to the story or set anything in
motion what this idea does in my mind is
that it works as a rational explanation
if you don't want to believe that
something Supernatural is happening or
that anyone else could be out there with
them it is a point of view you could
have but narratively speaking I feel
like there almost has to be at least one
other person out there Javi was supposed
to have found the Queen card and now no
one can ask him about that so how is
that supposed to happen if that was Ty
or why did Nat see him bowing to the
symbol tree and if it was a person or if
you prefer a supernatural entity that
could explain what happened to Crystal's
body which is another question that we
have if Javi has a friend would that
friend then be motivated to murder
everyone else in the cabin that's a
little harder to parse but it could be
for revenge for killing hobby I mean
that's a pretty obvious one that's right
there either way I do think if it was
Ben you can see how he might arrive at
that conclusion Not only would he be at
risk as someone who is firmly outside
the group and as someone who is made up
of a lot of calories they could use but
also based on his reaction to seeing
Shawna butchering Hobby's body he wasn't
there to see how things played out and
when he talked in that she only said she
let him die in her place as far as he
can tell things are getting out of
control and seeing the group rewarding
that for what he would perceive as her
depravity could be enough to push him
over the line from his point of view his
survival without resorting to
cannibalism is proof that it's possible
so he shouldn't be that sympathetic to
their claims that eating each other is
the only way they could make it through
the winter perhaps the more interesting
question about Ben now is if there's a
chance he could still be alive in the
present the possibility of that is tied
to the biggest questions about the girls
where will they go live now and will
they blame the fire on Ben since he's
the only other person they know is out
there this is also tied into the
question of what kind of antler Queen
will not be Ben is food so you can see
the group coming to the conclusion that
he was responsible and that he paid the
ultimate price for this transgression he
also put together where the cave was
through things hobby said which means
they might be able to find it too Javi
was leading that in that direction and
she's the one that Ben told about it
they definitely need shelter and they
might want revenge how will Nat tackle
these problems as the new leader which
he still have compassion for Ben or does
serving the group mean that providing
the next meal overshadows any feeling
she might have the cave or what I
imagine is likely caves based on the
melted snow that was around other Mossy
trees they found during season 2 does
seem crucial for them finding shelter
besides that they would have to go back
to the plane to wait out the rest of
winter questions like does every tree
that has a symbol have a cave nearby or
are they all connected by a system of
tunnels come to mind but from what
little we've seen of the one it seems
clear that it's natural beyond the fire
ring the bones and the missing Lantern
there aren't any overt Signs of Life the
tree that Travis and Nat found in the
early part of the season when they were
looking for hobby felt rather far away
from the cabin so it'll be interesting
to see what's going on beneath the
ground one quick aside about how they
frame what happened and how that shapes
their next moves is that it's possible
that they would just blame the fire on
the Wilderness itself from there it
would also make sense that it was trying
to move them somewhere different and
depending on what they find living
underground could seem like an
improvement it's been a popular theory
that the antler Queen would be a role
that changes over time and you do have
to wonder if Natalie's Ascension
confirms that it's entirely possible
that they didn't know for sure who was
supposed to be in the costume when they
made the pilot but they certainly
planted seeds for it to be Lottie along
the way I think the detail of her
cutting her hair for offerings and the
locks of hair you see in that first
ritual makes me think that Lottie will
be in that costume at that time so the
question then becomes how many antler
Queens will there be and will shawna's
resentment that they made a point of
showing before the fire as she was
writing in her journal be a big part of
that another question I had that might
just be me overthinking a little
sloppiness in the way they put the fire
scene together is if everyone actually
made it out alive they went out of their
way to give us a group shot of everyone
huddled together watching the cabin burn
after they made it seem like van was the
last person to get out before the roof
starts collapsing in that there are
exactly nine people with Jen and Aquila
missing you do see those two running
around grabbing things inside the cabin
but never see them run out is the
implication here that those two
characters died in the fire that would
change things up considerably as far as
future hunts were concerned including
Ben there would be 10 survivors and in
the pit Girl scene you see at least
eight people on screen together that led
fans to think that there might be one
more Survivor who could show up in the
present day timeline but if the ones in
this group shot are the only ones left
then Mari would have to be the pit girl
which is the most popular idea anyways
and then the only one to show up in the
present timeline would be Melissa who is
not a major character at this point she
is a blonde though which means that
she's probably not the pit girl we know
Ben is not the pit girl so Jen would
have been the other option and I don't
really understand why you set up that
group shot and not have everyone who
survived be in it as far as the
characters we know are dead do you think
that we'll see adult Natalie in a
limited role like we saw Jackie at the
beginning of this season I think there
probably is some truth to the rumors
that Juliet Lewis wasn't interested in
being in the show anymore but regardless
how the adults deal with her loss is a
big question going forward with Misty
seeming to be the one that should be
affected the most now I know she's shown
herself to be remorseless in other
situations but in those cases she could
justify her actions based on the
circumstances here it's still an
accident but based on how we saw her
tell Walter that she killed her best
friend and the way that she looked makes
it seem like this will be harder to
justify away come to think of it the
whole adult timeline is just one big
question mark what is Lottie getting
locked up in the institution again mean
is that the end of the wellness center
and all of the heliotrope wearing people
including Lisa how do the sedekis move
on after what they've been through does
Ty just go back to being a state senator
and working through her divorce with
Simone presuming that she survived does
Lottie saying the Wilderness is pleased
with them and then telling man she'll
see mean that she'll make a miraculous
recovery from her cancer and where do
Walter and Misty take their relationship
from here Nat's death feels like it
could be the thing that leads them to
not wanting to have anything to do with
each other again as easily as it could
be the thing that brings them together
if it will serve as a catalyst and
Define the rest of what happens with
these adults in this timeline then their
goal would almost have to be Breaking
Free from its hold once and for all but
how would they go about doing that the
season 2 finale gave the impression that
Walter's plan to pin things on Kevin
worked but it also hinted that Cali kind
of liked being a part of how things
played out it also hinted that even
though everyone except Lottie and to a
lesser extent van was reluctant to
participate in the hunt they all sort of
got swept up in it once it got started
it's not a hundred percent clear what's
going on it looked like Ty might have
switched over to the other one which her
switching over and the man with no eyes
or ongoing questions that I don't think
we understand that much better after
this season even though we did get to
see a little bit more of how that works
and it's possible that Nat was going
along with the hunt because she brought
the knife with her and she intended to
kill Lottie if that's what needed to be
done but as Lottie pointed out after
Cali intervened they all do believe that
whatever it was that they experienced
out there in the wilderness is still
with them even if they don't think of it
as the Wilderness even if they think it
was just them all along doing those
things you know Lottie also pointed out
that what difference does that make
throughout the second season they've all
accepted that it is as big a part of
their lives right now as it was when
they were stranded so at the end of of
the day I guess how they move forward
might come down to what they could
perceive as being a reward from that
sacrifice based on lottie's comment the
van I think they're absolutely leaving
the option open for her to make a full
recovery from her cancer it's not to say
they couldn't go a different way this is
an outcome that would be harder for the
audience to write off as coincidence but
spontaneous remission is a thing that
happens there are a lot of other little
questions and things like what happened
to Steve and then Simone and of course
Sammy but the adult timeline was so
disconnected from everything Beyond
getting them together for the hunt by
the time we got there we'll have to see
how they recalibrate things in the new
season and I think that's a great place
to leave things let me know what burning
questions you have for Yellowjackets
season three after the season two finale
in the comments please like this video
If you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
foreign